A deleted demon, creepy motel visitors, and
a post-credits teaser setting up the next
Conjuring movie are some of the many scenes
cut from The Devil Made Me Do It.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing the fascinating scenes,
original ending and villain cut from The Conjuring
3!
Spoilers for the franchise ahead, so take
care.
In a departure from the haunted house theme
of the first two Conjuring movies, The Devil
Made Me Do It is more of a demonic detective
story with Ed and Lorraine searching for clues
that will eventually lead them to the Occultist's
underground lair.
However, in the trailers, there's a good deal
of footage that points to an alternate storyline
for how the Warrens discover the Occultist's
den.
Notice how the trailer shows Ed and Lorraine
opening the door together on her altar, compared
to the final movie where Lorraine finds the
room by herself after she goes to visit Kastner
alone and he reveals to her the truth about
his daughter and the tunnels.
In this earlier version of the movie, the
location also looks quite a bit different.
There's what looks like a tree behind the
altar, plus an animal which could be a goat
or perhaps even a ram, given we know the Occultist
developed her interest in Satanism from the
objects her father collected while investigating
the Disciples of the Ram.
Ed also carries a package with him into the
room which he uses to sweep everything off
the Occultist's altar in this deleted scene.
In the final movie, Ed doesn't arrive at the
altar room until the very end when he's under
the influence of the Occultist and is attacking
Lorraine.
And after Lorraine breaks him out of the trance,
he smashes the altar with a sledgehammer.
Some behind-the-scenes footage also shows
another different version of Lorraine going
to the altar room by herself than we get in
the finished movie.
We know this was deleted because Lorraine's
hair is up in this shot, rather than down
as it is in the final film at this point,
and she's also got a bandage on her hand.
An intriguing deleted scene teased in the
trailer, but which never made it into the
final film, is of Ed and Lorraine during their
stay at a motel while investigating the Jessica
and Katie case.
In this cut scene, Ed is on the phone, but
Lorraine has been distracted by something,
a row of creepy shadows outside the motel
window, which feel like they're looking in
on the Warrens.
You can tell this is a motel and not the Warren
house, because of the Do Not Disturb sign
on the door knob, and I think this could have
been another of the optical illusions that
the Occultist is able to perform.
A particularly cool moment teased in the trailers
which sadly didn't make it into the final
film was this shot of multiple copies of Lorraine
endlessly spiralling into the distance.
This would have been a visual trick cast by
the Occultist while she was pursuing Lorraine
through the tunnels.
This moment was foreshadowed during the opening
scenes of David's exorcism, when the camera
that Drew was filming with was knocked over.
As the camera continued to record the monitor
it was connected to, an image of the screen
began to replicate itself infinitely, in a
very similar pattern to what happens to Lorraine
in this deleted scene.
In the final movie, we get a kind of cut-down,
somewhat simplified version of this trippy
visual, with a double of Lorraine appearing
in front of her and mirroring her movements.
Although this was still a nice effect that
suitably freaked Lorraine out, it's a shame
we didn't get the full-on sequence teased
at the beginning of the movie.
Another deleted scene from the trailers are
these shots of the police searching for a
body.
This is the water below the cliff that Lorraine
nearly fell down while she was investigating
Katie's murder at the hands of Jessica.
These scenes were probably cut for pacing
and time in the final version;
however, they might also be another indicator
of reshoots in the movie, because it could
explain why in the final film, a bandage suddenly
appears on Lorraine's hand after she almost
falls off the cliff, even though she didn't
seem to hurt her hand when Ed rescued her.
Although it is possible it's an injury from
that fall, it might hint that something else
happened to Lorraine during these deleted
scenes.
A curious deleted scene in one of the trailers
shows Arne standing on the edge of a prison
building with a chain around his neck, looking
like he might be about to kill himself.
In the movie, the Occultist tries to get Arne
to commit suicide, like Jessica when she ran
off the cliff, in order to complete the curse
she cast on him.
Some fans were a little disappointed that
The Devil Made Me Do It didn't dive so much
into the details of Arne Johnson's court trial,
and although I doubt it was ever going to
be the main focus, there's some behind-the-scenes
footage of Ed addressing reporters outside
the courthouse which wasn't in the final movie,
hinting that there may have been more courtroom
drama filmed but cut from the finished film.
A publicity still of Lorraine, Ed, Drew and
Debbie forming a prayer circle indicates another
scene that was nowhere to be found in the
final movie.
This moment looks like it would have appeared
around the time that the Warrens and the team
are trying to figure out the key to breaking
the curse put on Arne by the Occultist, and
I suspect the prayer was cut for time.
A major change that might explain why there
appear to have been reshoots on the film is
that in early versions of the movie there
was a specific demon that the Occultist was
communicating with.
In the final film, although a reference is
made to the Occultist having summoned a demon,
"This demon...
it's not here of its own free will.
It was summoned."
we never see its form and instead at the end,
when the curse has been broken, it's a copy
of the Occultist which comes to take her soul.
In an interview with SlashFilm, director Michael
Chaves said that originally they had a demon
that matched the description that the real-life
David Glatzel and Arne Johnson had given to
them about the demonic entity they claimed
had possessed them.
Producer James Wan was on board with the demon,
and a cut of the film with the demon does
in fact exist.
However, it appears that the interaction between
the demon and the Occultist was too complicated
and confusing for test audiences which Chaves
puts down to this being the first time a human
antagonist has featured in the franchise.
At the time of filming, Chaves was actually
expecting the demon to end up with his own
spin-off film,
but admitted that it just didn't click and
had to be replaced in a similar way to how
the original antagonist of The Conjuring 2,
a winged, horned demon ended up being replaced
by the demonic nun Valak during reshoots.
Because Chaves felt bad for the actor Davis
Osborne who'd played the original demon, he
decided to give him the part of the prison
hospital patient who mocks and taunts Arne.
The Devil Made Me Do It also originally had
a post-credits scene that would have set up
a future Conjuring Universe movie.
In an interview with NME, Chaves revealed
that the deleted credits teaser was an expansion
on the villains introduced in this movie;
however, similar to the demon problem, it
was confusing and therefore removed, to give
the film a more solid, definitive ending.
Chaves hasn't yet said what was in the scene
but I wonder whether it could have alluded
to the return of Valak in a fourth Conjuring
movie, or perhaps a sequel to The Nun?
There were already a few teases to Valak in
the film, such as the nun figurine in Arne's
bedroom,
but as TITAN BR pointed out on my Things You
Missed video, there was also this photograph
of the Occultist when she was younger and
in the background towards the window, there
seems to be a mysterious shape which could
be a blurry and somewhat indistinct or semi-transparent
Nun's habit.
The date on the photograph is 1952 which is
the year that the main events of The Nun take
place, something which suggests the filmmakers
want to tease a potential connection between
the two movies.
We have had the demonic nun hidden in the
background of a photo before in the franchise,
for example in the photo that Sister Charlotte
showed to Samuel Mullins in Annabelle Creation.
Perhaps this post-credits scene would have
shown the Occultist having been previously
in contact with Valak in some way.
Another possibility is that she was visited
by Frenchie who in 1952 was possessed by Valak
during the events of The Nun movie.
Alternately, the credits scene might have
expanded on the connection between the Occultist
and the Disciples of the Ram, the cult from
the first Annabelle movie that was mentioned
several times in The Devil Made Me Do It.
We know from Father Kastner that the Disciples
of the Ram were especially evil and vindictive
and that after the cults' members were tried
and found guilty, the lead prosecutor's wife
and baby both suffered terrible fates.
If any of the cult are still around or if
they can break out of prison, they might target
Ed and Lorraine for helping to take down the
Occultist, something that could be the set-up
for the next Conjuring or Annabelle movie.
"A master Satanist is not an adversary to
be taken lightly."
The credits scene might also have been setting
up the Crooked Man spin-off movie that's currently
in development based on the villain from the
haunted turntable in the Conjuring 2.
Whatever the scene entails, we'll hopefully
get to see it as Chaves said the scene may
be coming back in another form, hinting that
it'll be worked into an upcoming movie or
perhaps even as a deleted clip for the movie's
Blu-ray release.
And if you want to learn all about how The
Devil Made Me Do It connects with the Nun
and the Annabelle movies plus all the horror
movie easter eggs in the film, tap here to
watch my things you missed video or follow
the link in the video description.
So, do you wish any of these deleted scenes
had been in the final movie?
And what Conjuring film are you looking forward
to next?
Let me know in the comments below.
If you enjoyed this, leave a thumbs-up;
and a share is also hugely appreciated.
Tap left to discover the even more horrifying
original ending of The Nun or tap right for
something else you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!